-♪♪ Do, do, do ♪♪
♪♪ Wheel of Opinions ♪♪
-Yeah!
-Now, here's how it works.
You're going to hit this button
right here, which activates
the opinion topic generator, and
it'll land on a random topic.
Whatever it is, I have a feeling
you are going to have
a good opinion about it.
[ Light laughter ]
-All right.
-Are you ready for this?
-Yes.
-All right, press the button
when you're ready.
Here we go.
Watch, you'll see.
It'll pop up.
Technology, watch.
I'll do it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Beeping ]
Oh, we almost had spanx,
but all right.
[ Laughter ]
It was almost spanx.
You know what I mean?
Do you like spanx?
-Well...
-No?
-...I got stuff to say about
spanx, I mean --
[ Laughter ]
-Spanx.
-Anyways, online dating.
-No.
Online dating, man, I don't like
it, cause I feel like that's
where I meet a lot of creeps...
[ Laughter ]
...dudes that come off like they
have, like,
the really nice picture
and you're like, "Oh,
I can't wait to meet him,"
and then you go to the Starbucks
to meet him, and you're like
"Oh, my God,
he is a booger wolf." and --
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
-Okay, that's good.
All right, we're ready for --
-No, I wasn't finished!
His breath smell like he's been
eating eggs for days.
-All right, hey, come on.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I ain't finished yet!
His beard is ashy!
He got an ashy beard.
[ Light laughter ]
No, I ain't finished yet.
He tells you he's got good
credit, and then you figure out
his birth date and look it up,
and you find out he's got
a credit score of 200.
[ Ding ]
I ain't finished yet.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
"I ain't finished" is a new
character.
All right, let's go to the next
one, ready?
[ Beeping ]
"I ain't finished" is a new
character I want to see.
Popcorn, what?
Those strawberry candies --
-That Grandmas always have.
-You know those things.
-Oh, them strawberry candies --
them strawberry -- them cheap
strawberry candies
that grandma's always have.
They try to give them to you
in church, when you're like,
a little colicky, they're like,
"Hey, take this candy
right here."
And the candy's nasty 'cause
it's old, and it seems like
always the kids --
it's shaped like a little
strawberry, so you think,
"Oh, it's going to be delicious
like a strawberry,"
but it tastes like plastic
and sugar.
And then it's always in --
You know I be raiding kids'
Halloween trick-or-treat
candies, --
-Yeah.
-And they always be in there,
and that's how I know they went
to a geriatric's home
to get candy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And it makes your breath stink!
Them candies make your breath
smell like you've been eating
eggs for three days.
-Oh, hey! I'm not finished!
-And another thing!
I ain't finished yet,
and another thing!
[ Laughter ]
-All right, ready, here we go,
one more.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
-The woods?
-Oh, no.
Now, the woods can be a
wonderful thing,
and it can be a scary thing.
Now, personally for me, if I go
to the woods it better have
a toilet.
[ Laughter ]
Also, it better have a place
where I can wash my ass.
-All right, hey!
-Now, what I like most about
the woods
is you can get freaky
in the woods,
but I be scared at the same
times because what
if Jason in the woods?
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
Them scary movies,
they always be getting killed in
the woods.
-Yeah.
-But I go to the woods, though.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
Englewood!
-Oh, Englewood.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
That's all the time we have
for "Wheel of Opinions."
My thanks to Tiffany Haddish.
Who are you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who are you, man?
-I'm Tiffany Haddish.
-We'll be right back...